所以我的一天才刚刚开始
一节
一节我是个白日梦想家
现在我只想做个生意十干假
对我来说生活很简单
不过是同样的一天
重复一万次
生活也很难
难的是重复并不是我的梦想
工作久了
就会发现人会变得十顿
比如说以前我会的音乐很敏感
每个一段时间总会出现一段旋律
能够直接我的内心
让我感动很多年
那这种感觉已经很久没有出现过了
为了完成这个五老个配月
我这几天一直犯了复决的这听
各种平台的音乐
我的内心已经强大到
没有一点
已经没有一个多丑上感的心
来对世界的悲患离和感动深受了
我有很多时间上半时间下半时间
工作时间
睡觉时间
起床时间娱乐时间
防待时间亲自的时间
很多人总喜欢把生活拆的秘密白白
满满荡荡暗不就搬
来我
我
只想忘记时间
为什么做视频
因为我喜欢
为什么之前没做
也许
是因为我有太多时间了
或者总是被打断
这些外部音速度就是借口
如果这样的话也不能算是热爱吧
毕竟如果发自内心的喜欢的时候
就可以想进一切办法的去打到
毕竟
如果真的发自内心的喜欢
就会想进一切办法去打到
我想是的
我觉得一个农村的窮小子
一个农村的窮小子
不该这么交情
还有一些原因
比如说
水平不够、懒斗、油育
不坚定、不知性
觉得自己做不好
害怕失败
会温自己、失败了怎么办
你问我怎么办
两半朝鸡蛋、两半朝鸡蛋
两半朝鸡蛋已经两块半
我经常害怕
我经常害怕看到视频
一来
一险下来我的脑子
就更喜欢吃那些垃圾
来消化不动这种干户
这是大展的规律
二来
我怕我真的学会了
那如果有时候一不小心
涉入到这些交场
但是如果有时候一不小心
但是有时候如果一不小心
涉入到这些视频
那早够了
循环开始
打击血
开始折腾
遇到阻挨
被打断
停一下
我总是在折腾自己
这样的循环很尴尬
但我乐死不疲
可能我只是在自救
证明自己还活着
那一个火苗
我觉得一个火苗
至少单纯吃了
我不想放弃
我好像我经常有时候感觉
我好像迷失在了黑洞
努力争大爷
却什么也
却什么都看不到
我好像迷失在了黑洞
努力争大爷
却什么都看不到
每当我尝试我
黑洞中打击书光
那书光就不见了
但我不知道
我为什么一直在重复自救
重复这个过程
但是我为什么一直在重复自救
黑洞外面
究竟是什么
黑洞外面究竟是谁
但我为什么一直重复自救
跟那一条
无论何时你都要记得
因为因为因为
因为我想让你知道
无论何时你都要记得